I have no interest in sucking up to Tomb
Raider it's one of my favorite recent
games and I've been raving about it for
almost a year but it wasn't flawless in
fact its problems are so obvious and so
glaring that they have echoed loudly
from every corner of the interweb
which makes Crystal Dynamics job all the
easier we know there's gonna be a secret
so let's figure out how they can improve
on their already impressive reboots
thank you
logic is important and as well-developed
as Lara is he kind of skips a few step
in her rise from scholar to kill him
exploring the psychological toll of
ending another human's life is a great
idea and there are certainly moments
when my stomach clenched when I saw how
tormented Lara was but that feeling
would vanish when I get alley air out a
cluster of creeps so how about this
give me the player more agency and what
kind of person she is
when I happened upon an occupied camp
give me a decision maybe mylar is a
touch psychotic maybe she wants to douse
herself in the blood of her foes Who am
I to judge or maybe she'd rather avoid
the fight completely
why shouldn't archaeologists bear arms
anyway with more flexible combat I'd be
able to decide exactly how she handles
difficult situations and based on how I
act her story would change have her
mutter angry curses under her breath
when rushing into the fray or pleading
quietly to avoid confrontation a dynamic
story and flexible combat would
eliminate much of that narrative
weirdness that so many complained about
there was only the slightest bit of tomb
raiding in tomb raider that's really
weird
Laura may be able to fight Laura may be
able to rescue her captured friends and
collected and doodads but she's a raider
first and foremost so that should be a
core part of the game crazy I know but
this shouldn't be too difficult to fix
as much as I love the huge environments
with scattered treasure it didn't make
much sense
why would Laura hunt Condor nests anyway
if the outside environments were used
more for platforming challenges while
the tombs were filled with ancient
artifacts and puzzles it would add great
diversity and be logical sounds ideal to
me
I've ranted about regenerating health
for so long I just assumed people have
tuned me out but I really don't care
going from near death to full strength
by standing still for three seconds is
super dumb it eliminates the fear of
confrontation and destroys any attempt
at a logical narrative there I said it
so what if the new to mayor got rid of
that system completely I know there are
people shaking their head at the mere
thought of this but plenty of beloved
games have required healing items
instead did you already forget about the
Last of Us yeah and while we're
emphasizing that whole survivor aspect
what if Lara needed to find food and
shelter Tomb Raider already came so
close to realizing this I totally killed
scores of deer and bunnies why not make
it a necessity instead of a choice and
what if Lara had to find actual clothes
you know something more protective than
a tank top don't get me wrong I wouldn't
want the next Tomb Raider become a
fashion show and I don't think you
should have to spend hours chopping wood
for a shelter like in rust but some hint
that you're a survivor on a scary Island
we pretty cool oh and for the love of
all that is good and holy just scrap the
multiplayer no one wants it just to make
the best damn single-player possible